it's a shimmering emerald on an autumn
night that is hosting a postseason game
for the 88th time
from the babe to pudge to big poppy to
[ __ ] so much history is written on this
field
who will be next eduardo rodriguez 28
years old from venezuela
and there are the numbers this post
season after winning 13 games during the
regular year
altuve hits it in the air to center for
[ __ ] hernandez
deepest part of this yard one out and
bradley in this series is one for nine
and he swings and misses he got a fast
ball by him well he was really late on
that swing 96 and a good sign for
rodriguez feeding off his last start i
think he gained some confidence he
didn't have his best stuff through the
pitch swing ground ball left side raffy
dives gets it
whirls throws out at first
raffy devers a standing race to his left
grab their world around and through a
strike to first one two three they go
after half an inning
against the right hander jose or keady
who's making his first appearance in 15
days that means
he has yet to appear this postseason and
the manager is hoping he's in rhythm
fly ball into right over to his left is
tucker one away yeah he got that one off
the end of the batter kitty is you know
four seam fastball 92-93 you mentioned
he's gonna throw it on top of the zone
get some fly balls to set up that change
up
popped up straight up on the infield
guriel comes in from first two out and
that's a big second out getting a very
hot hitter hernandez two out of nobody
on for third baseman rafael devers three
for nine in the alcs with a home run and
four runs batted in here's the 01.
endeavors pops it up left side to the
infield bregman over has a play now on
to the grass moving back behind the
mound and makes the catch to retire the
side a one two three first for erkidi
with a couple of infield pop-ups
rodriguez looks like he's got a little
something here tonight two out nobody on
crowd gets into it and he kicks into 2-2
swinging in a miss strike three blew him
away with a high heater he strikes out
the side
and eduardo is fanned for the last five
batters njd works had the grand slam in
game two he's hitting 391 this
postseason with two homers
that is a rocket into left center field
gonna bang off the wall verdugo is
flying around second and now he's held
at third
and a wise hold by carlos feyblace and a
double by jd martinez maybe about eight
feet up on that fw website in left
center
and the red sox runners at second and
third
here it is
outside ball four missed with a slider
so he works the walk full-blown
conference happening right now as
christian vasquez will come to the plate
with the bases loaded
[Applause]
one run scores they will hold martinez
at third on the throw home and the red
sox lead one to nothing on an rbi hit by
vasquez yeah rikidi goes back to that
slider after a couple of fastballs this
ball is up this is off the plate you
know a few inches off the plate but it
was up in the zone retired the first
four did her kitty and he has sprung a
leak since then with two walks
might be off the mound off el tube
two-nothing boston and you know altoona
is not that big so that bounce went way
higher than he anticipated and it caught
him too high up to where he couldn't get
the glove on it still loaded one out for
schwarber to fly ball to right his first
time up two-nothing boston he kicks and
he delivers swing there's a long drive
to right field deep toward the
grandstand tucker looking up it is gone
into the grandstand grand slam kyle
schwarber
six nothing red sox can you believe it
3-0
3-0 i'm hacking what do you mean
families don't you give me the take
oh i'm gonna get one down the middle and
schwarber hits just a mile
oh this is beautiful we said the ball
wasn't flying that one did
amazing
as many in the last two games as they
hit the entire regular season and the
first team in postseason history with
three grand slams in one series good
thing those guys legitimately like each
other that's the smallest green room for
the biggest people those are big dudes
one on one out a strikeout a walk runner
is going throw down is
into center field
up and over to third goes renfro and now
he'll be content with just getting to
third
little fly ball shallow left
brantley is gonna play it on a hop and
then to score his renfro
it's seven to nothing boston there's one
out runner on first here's the pitch
driven to left field way back is it high
enough
it is a bloop and a blast and it's nine
nothing red sox the hit parade continues
for boston
18 home runs in the postseason now for
the red sox in their eighth game tucker
into the box cast the plate a couple of
times left on left match up three
infielders on the right
here's a high fly ball into right back
at the wall it is out of here
three-run home run for kyle tucker and
the astros are on the board it's nine to
three scored a ton of runs this
postseason have the astros with two outs
he's going to take a mountain of this
this game to come back here's the 1-2
and he takes strike three he got a
sinker in there down and in maldonado
complaining as he walks back but bill
miller rings him up one out strikeout
number six yeah this was paint here's
the 0-1 swinging a pop-up huge he should
get him a one-two-three inning christian
coming back down the dirt makes the
catch so eddie rebounds in the fifth
inning
with a quick one two three frame maybe
one more who knows after four and a half
nine three red sox
swinging a miss he struck him out with a
change up it is all working for eddie
and they're two down here's correa over
two strikeout and the pop out the 3-1
pitch swinging a line hopper to second
arroyo to a knee he comes up throwing
inning over and you can bet that alex
gore has got a huge embrace for eduardo
rodriguez waiting in the dugout listen
to the hand for eddie after getting
carlos correa who was pointing in his
watch in game one when he hit that go
ahead a home run in the seventh yeah
he's going to tell him right here great
job but no need to do anything like that
oh and one to jd
there it goes
adios way out of here
martinez with a shot
it's 11-3
little hang piece little hanger up jd
deposits the left fields crushes this
ball raffy swings and drives a high fly
to left back by the wall mccormick looks
up gone
into the monster's seat second roll
raffi with a first pitch home run an
opposite field shot
12-3 red sox his fourth home run and his
11th rbi in this postseason
on his 46th birthday alex cora and his
red sox about to go up two games to one
there's a drive to right field on comes
renfro dives in did he trap it oh he
caught it he caught it for the athlete
ends the ball game
brilliant diving catch by hunter renfro
and the red sox lead the series two
games to one nicola vulture organic
seltzer as real as it tastes